[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: What was
different about your body
when you were born?
EZRA FRECH: I was
actually born with one
finger on my left hand
and a full left leg,
but it was curved.
I had surgery when I was 2
and 1/2 years old to remove
the part that was curved.
So I had a stump that they
could put a prosthetic leg on.
And then they took
the big toe from that.
And they put it on my left hand.
So I have two fingers.
I did tons of physical
therapy to try
to get my new finger to
work like a real finger,
and not like a toe.
I was always trying to figure
out how to bring them together
and how to get them to
come together and touch.
And I was sitting in the shower.
And they touched.
And then it was amazing.
I was running around the house
screaming, yay, I did it.
Because that was
the first milestone.
LAURA LING: Do you feel
different than other kids?
EZRA FRECH: Sometimes I do.
People do stare and whisper.
I'll be thinking, there's
tons of kids in this world.
How did he happen to choose me
to be one of the kids that had
to get their leg taken away.
And I asked God, can
you please give me
a leg, somehow, some way.
But then I have to think,
I was born like this.
I can't change it.
And when I play sports,
I don't feel different.
I don't think about
anything else.
I just think about what's
happening in the game.
LAURA LING: Would you say sports
have become a ritual for you?
EZRA FRECH: Yes.
Because I feel like if I
don't play sports every day,
I feel weird.
I've always felt like sports
is where I can go when
I'm sad or lonely or anything.
I love competition.
I love the feeling.
I love being under
pressure and everything.
When I'm playing sports, I
go from thinking about all
the other things to game mode.
When I'm in the
zone, I feel like I
have this fire around me.
And then the flames pop up and
have this circle around it.
So any thoughts
that try to come in,
and they get burned by the fire.
And they don't let in.
LAURA LING: Do you feel you have
to work harder than other kids?
EZRA FRECH: Oh, yes.
I bet kids, when they take
a step, oh, I took a step.
Big deal.
For me, when I take a step,
I say, oh, no big deal.
But I thought about
every little bit.
I put so much
pressure on my body
from being in a prosthetic
all day, I come home.
I'm like dying from back pain.
And I have to stretch before
I go to bed every night.
LAURA LING: So how
do you stay positive?
EZRA FRECH: I have to
think about what I have
instead of what I don't have.
I have a great life.
I have a great family.
I have great legs.
I have great friends.
I have a great school.
I could go on for years.
I'm just grateful that I
have so many things that
are great in my life.
There's lots of challenges
in people's life.
And that's a little
wall right there.
So I try to break
down that wall.
If I'm just running around
playing soccer or shooting
a lay-up, I don't
think about it.
I don't feel different
when I'm playing.
Sports because that takes
me away from my disability.
But it's a good thing
that I'm born like this.
I've learned to be
confident in myself.
I've learned how to be strong.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Firefighters see
difficult things every day.
Click to watch as one
shares his inspiring
ritual in this episode.
SUBJECT: All that excitement,
energy, sweat, tears,
it's contained until you get
all the way up to the top,
where you just explode and
just feel the sky open up.
EZRA FRECH: "Rituals" is a
part of "Seeker Stories."
If you'd like to
continue to see more
stories from around the world,
we need you to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.